[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Lincoln I'm
Rhett joining us today not at the round
table of dim lighting but in a
relatively well-lit room at VidCon are
some mythical beasts that's right this
is the first-ever what did we just
decide we're call it a live record a
live recording cuz your biscuits are
alive and this is being recorded in
front of people your biscuits and so
this is experimental
we normally sit kind of across from each
other or at a 90 degree angle from one
another right when doing ear bist we're
in a good mythical morning configuration
right that's kind of weird Co we're
doing I've never seen you with
headphones you know you've looked at me
while we've done this but it does make
me be more aware of how we typically
record on your biscuit that yeah you're
right it's it's dimly lit we're at the
round table a little usually leaning
back if there's not a guest we're still
like it's not like we're constantly
looking at each other there might be an
occasional glance like when are you
gonna shut up so I can talk but we have
a little line so we have a little cues
because when two people interview one
person first of all we have built-in
redundancy so if one of us passes out
during the interview with the other
person picks up or dies let's just go
all the way this really what the whole
design of this thing was about was that
we could continue this thing when one of
us passes away but during an air biscuit
you may notice that sometimes we do
start talking at the same time sometimes
that's edited out if it's really
embarrassing but there are like little
like I'm because I'm embarrassing when
we talk at the same time coming in like
the hand has to come in a little bit
early and we just not being recorded
sometimes I think the guest thinks we're
coming in for like a throat jam or
something I'm like yeah I don't have to
do that today cuz the irony is a we're
talking at the same time right now and
be I've never seen this signal so it's
like totally not worked
that's another thing - I've no clue
talking to look straight for a second so
if you have glasses you may notice that
your peripheral vision often is
compromised yeah I can't see you at all
you know so I'm gonna be good right now
apparently I've been making this hand
signal for two years for no one except
me except mines we should have talked
about this yes sometimes I thought we
had a system like a fingertip might fly
in sometimes I'm like what I just saw
like did I just catch a fingertip it's
like no that like this right I'll reach
out in front just actually just pull my
ear it's like a form of pull my fingers
you that involved it's just for podcast
okay but still involves passing gas mmm
so moving right along the idea today is
we're gonna take some questions that
were submitted on the internet and also
some questions that were submitted in
real life like you and your answer them
in no particular order I hit the
handwriting here is it's fabulous
quizzes thanks for doing that and thanks
for waiting to come in and I know a lot
of you guys were waiting for quite some
time so so are we it's which made it
weird we could have just no just kidding
okay let's get a question here this is
Julie's at jalisa
Lee oh three tweeted at us what was your
first impression of each other PS I love
you guys various emoticons arts I do
have a very specific memory of link in
first grade that first day that we met
if you know the story about being held
in from recess because we wrote
profanity on our desks in Miss
Locklear's class we had to sit there
just the two of us coloring and I
specifically remember like I'm I'm a
first grader and I was I think a typical
first grader at least according to how
my son's have been and it was kind of
like I have a crayon and I'm just doing
this you know just like this boot needs
in all the area around it needs to be
read and very dark and then by this you
mean emotion
like you've got a fist but you're making
a motion as if you're like chopping down
trees like erratically right but that's
me coloring yeah and then I look over
and Link is like really right inside of
these lines and it's really light and
it's very calculated I was like what is
wrong with this kid I'm a meticulous man
I was like it's the most he's taking so
much time in approaching this with so
much care how is this possible I've
never seen anything like this I was just
thinking probably because I don't
remember but I was knowing myself now
and projecting it back to then I'm
pretty sure I was thinking man I don't
want to screw this up because I don't
want to be trapped in here with this guy
tomorrow at recess it's like I thought
it was some sort of aptitude test it's
like I'm beating this guy I'm not gonna
be in here tomorrow so yeah I sadly I'm
sure that there was some sort of feeling
analyzed like I was performing for
somebody but it would also make you
uncomfortable if I had a dis reached
over and like colored your boot oh that
would kill me man yeah you couldn't
handle that yeah we would it would have
been we wouldn't have been friends we
would have right fault
let me read another question Colin all
capital letters with spaces in between
each letter asks what was your dream job
as a child so okay we're still we're
still in child them yeah here in your
childhood usually my dream job as a
child was to be a weatherman not a
meteorologist but a weatherman so
growing up an unqualified meteorologist
I mean let's just first of all David
Letterman was a weatherman
he was Pat Sajak was a weatherman he's
the host of will of fortune that is a
show you may be familiar with which is
our standard of excellence in all things
but I actually thought there's no wheel
involved I want no part of it I actually
thought when I was 5 years old no that's
right too young too old for years old
that you're making it up it could be no
age you want
Pat Sajak was on the weather in
California the local weather I actually
lived out here when I was like 3 4 or 5
I saw him doing the weather and I
thought that my dad was doing the
weather because he my dad looks just
like Pat Sajak and it's about the same
height he's five nine a lot of people
don't know that anyway my dad is not Pat
Sajak he has never done the weather I
don't even know I brought that up what
was the question
oh you wanted to be a weatherman yeah
because Bob debarred 11 yeah the real
weatherman was looking awesome I mean
his name was Bob debarred 11 and that's
that was enough for me I mean he was on
television every night and he like
here's a local celebrity he he he served
he was a friend who told me what you
know the conditions were going to be in
my environment like a the weather
it just seemed he was important you know
yeah like how are you gonna know what
the weather's gonna be now Bob know in
like five days into the future the dude
was magical yeah yeah he's like a prize
of profit the weather promised and he
was bald
yeah so he looked like a prophet they're
all bald right yeah by the end yeah okay
what about you what was your dream job
as a child I wanted to be an architect
and I would from a very early age I
would make floor plans for homes like at
age six like would you charge for it no
I would just I got a charge from it
doing it okay dad but but you this was a
service you know for me anybody any
given these were these were
like a six-year-old kid these were
hypothetical analysis yeah and there was
no structural engineering you know
approach to this but I would literally I
don't know what was wrong with me I
don't know but in any given time you
could walk into my room and I would like
have this elaborate floorplan would like
doors and this is the bedroom this is
the bathroom like I was like oh yeah
like an overhead blueprint right yeah
that's what yeah it was a 2d floor plan
link I didn't do any 3d I didn't make
anything even make do any folds or
anything oh you didn't you didn't
incorporate or it wasn't an origami
house and I wanted to do that for a long
time and you got a you but you you got a
civil engineering degree but the reason
I got a sibling god it was somehow
related well no well no it is related
because the structural and civil
engineering department at NC State
University is the same building is the
same you you just kind of go to the same
classes and then it branches off and
then once I got into it I was like this
is hard and there and I was like which
one's easier and they're like well the
one that where you'd make ditches is the
easy one you know the one where you put
water through pipes something that a
farmer could do probably without an
engineering degree that's the one that I
chose and that's what I ended up getting
a degree in so what are we concluding it
in some way I'm living my dream
I mean sometimes I'm in front of a green
screen and there could be weather on it
mm-hmm
if we want if we so chose right you know
and I could I have access to like
weather forecasts that I could relay to
people yeah it without having a degree
which is what a weatherman is but you
you just abandoned your dreams have been
shattered all right I no longer make
floor plans I'm sorry for pointing that
out
lay low no low lead wobba that's I said
this last name that's her name she is
awesome
have you guys ever seriously hurt or
come close to seriously hurting
yourselves while filming you first since
that you have the easier answer I'm sure
I don't think no I'm not I don't think
I've ever hurt my
self while filming definitely not
seriously but you've been hurt and then
we had to film something and it it was
potentially seriously compromised I'm
talking about the Conan thing with your
back oh yeah yeah yeah so you may know I
have back issues it's it I don't have
them right now necessarily there it's
just long yeah it's a very long back so
something's bound to be compromised and
right after we moved to LA when we were
we were working on commercial Kings
there's you know when you do a
television show there's all these like
there's the PR side of it in the press
tour and so that was how we were able to
become guests on Conan O'Brien show and
the like two days before we were
supposed to go on I threw my back out it
turns out it was how did you throw your
back I was eating a sandwich but that's
that's true I lit as a large sandwich a
lot of meat on it
oh and as I'm not kidding as I was as I
was well it turns out I mean this is
probably you know it's common to throw
your back out eating sandwiches because
well what happens is what I was told
later is or you probably did something
before the sandwich and then it just
happened to be while you're eating the
sandwich that it went out so I was in
extreme pain like I couldn't really
stand up I definitely could not walk
straight without leaning very hard to
one side so much so that I was like you
know we have to walk out from behind
that curtain in like Sheikh Conan's hand
and sit down and it was gonna be a
disaster
we thought we had to address it that we
had to become the whole thing I remember
when I first saw you
like I mean you texted me you're like
sandwich back bad we need plan call the
weatherman or something but when I saw
you even though you'd prepared me it was
how I described it it's like you were
walking towards me like came in the room
very slowly and it was I guess it's like
if you had a freeze-frame
of what could be like the most painful
part of like a contortionist act or like
someone dodging a punch constantly like
right but knowing that they're still
gonna get hit so their face is like no
but and as I don't want to be on Conan
with this guy well and you may not know
this but you probably have picked up on
this that when you're on a talk show the
host is asked is just feeding the
pre-prepared questions to the comedian
or whoever it is so they can say the
four or five things that they've that
they're cut they've already come up with
and he knows exactly what questions are
gonna be asked so cuz a producer calls
you ahead of time and they're like okay
this is what we're gonna ask you do you
guys have anything else that you want to
talk about let's work it out so you kind
of work out like we're gonna show this
clip and you're Conan's gonna ask this
question and we're gonna tell this story
but then we were like there's something
we need to mention and and that's that
my back is hurt so bad that we feel like
we may have to address it but he was
like okay we'll just play that by ear
you could kind of tell you it's like I
don't want your back to be a part of
this man but then when we got there
there's so much adrenaline just from
being on a show like that that you were
healed there was absolutely no problem I
felt absolutely no pain you can watch
and it doesn't look like I'm in pain cuz
I wasn't but as soon as the show was
over it was horrible oh I forgot that
part really yeah I was horrible I didn't
tell you about that III kind of I'll try
to leave you out of this link so you
don't have to share the burden I have
enough pain of my own so right but you
have been seriously hurt while filming
yeah and I'll keep this one short
because there's a whole video I mean
it's I think it's called links fall fail
is that what it's called it's on our
second channel but basically I thought
it would be cool to run at top speed for
like an interstitial for commercial
Kings
and I just felt I didn't fall flat on my
face I actually fell on like 18
different parts of my body and rapid
succession but it was caught in Sun King
in such a way that like we can analyze
it in slow motion and make a video out
of it well and this sadly has been seen
more than the television show so it was
for the interstitial stuff like as we
were cutting to commercial are coming
back from commercial on the show they
had these little needle vignettes and so
this one where link nearly died it's it
was it's violent you know he was hurt so
bad so it's like something you would
show to kids before he broke his elbow
you saw that they don't run to prom you
broke your elbow right or just it was
they couldn't find a break but it was
dislocated I know it was it was it was
bad and it was and it affected him for a
while but it affected him so much she
was like we have to put this in every
episode so in every episode of
commercial Kings before the commercial
break you like here's a question from
the room no name is on it but you know
your handwriting who asked this question
how does making videos affect your
family life how did they take the news
that you are going to do youtube
full-time it's somebody you're awesome
you're in take credit right there don't
be shy your edit take credit how did
they take the news that you're gonna do
YouTube full times like well I mean we
didn't like sitting down like kids your
parents are splitting up
actually actually we did well it
interestingly our wives are one of the
reasons that we were doing what we're
doing right now because we told the
stories some capacity somewhere but
going back to right out of college when
we're working as engineers we wrote a
song for our roommate Greg's wedding
rehearsal dinner right we basically
wanted to make fun of him in front of
his whole family and warn his fiancee
that like it's not too late to change
your mind in a song and it was actually
the song was later the lyrics were all
changed and it became the unibrow song
which was like one of the first songs
ever on YouTube from us but this one was
all about Greg and like the wedding
night and how embarrassing it was gonna
be for both of them it says we've seen
Greg naked soon you will too hope you
enjoy it more than we do right that was
that was a chorus but but you probably
won't know we didn't say that and but we
did this song and like everybody really
reacted to it well and then all the way
back home where our wives who were like
you guys you guys should do there should
be more than just doing this like
wedding receptions you know you should
you should there's something here we
like you should really do something with
this right so now whenever you know
we're you we have to be a way to be here
or do something else that impacts our
family it's like well is it's your fault
yeah right there's your idea we put it
back on is that what you were yeah
getting that and then you know with with
the kids you know how do they take the
news that you're going to do YouTube
full-time it's just it's more it's more
of okay this is what dad does and it's
like no big deal really I think is what
all the kids would say it's interesting
that they're they now have friends who
find out that we are their parents are
one of us did that make sense
that hey are your parents one of them
one of them youtubers but they but
they're no but I got fine about it I
think it was kind of a everybody's dad
must do this until it was like oh okay
you watch my dad on the internet that's
weird
yeah yeah there I watch him at dinner
sometimes there but I try to look away
there's that's really annoying yeah
they're dealing with that in their their
social lives which might check in on
that which fright ask this one question
it is a ears a here's a family question
Brian asks how often do your families
interact oh well we definitely keep them
separated they don't add they actually
don't know about each other yeah right
no you know very often you know our our
kids are locked in Lincoln or like our
best friends and then Lando and Shepard
are our best friends it's really you
know it's it's cool to have to size I'm
yeah it's cool to see them to see our
friendship in their friendship well and
we have two chances of being replaced if
like again redundancy if locking Lincoln
end up just sucking you know then Lando
and Shepard are like the next in line
they can try and they can both do things
and I'm sure Lily will want to produce
the whole thing so she Lily's the oldest
of all the kids and but it was not girls
it wasn't engineers kind of an odd man
out it was not enjoy well she's a woman
not quite but it wasn't engineered and
there's always been this you know if
with our wives it was okay you guys
kinda have to be best friends now no one
ever said that but it was sort of like
this expectation that like okay well
either gonna be best friends or you're
gonna have to find a way to get along
but they they do get along and they are
best friends and then with the kids it
was like I wish you know
the first you know Lily was first and
then Locke who's a year younger than she
is but then Lincoln who and their grants
I should say that our good friends right
but they lock lock in Lincoln kind of
naturally - they're both boys they kind
of gravitated towards one another and
they sort of just naturally became great
friends they see each other all the time
and in Lando and Shepard are each
other's favorite person on earth and so
it's just that's how it's going right
now we're just like all right hands off
guys don't feel like you have to have a
YouTube channel or a website or anything
just be friends but there's like a
percolating assumption isn't there well
we have we don't talk about me we have
reserved all the web sites yes we do
have all the web sites reserved or at
least we'll say that so you don't do it
right now don't do it
yeah it's instead of just talking about
our wives though it would prep now it's
probably a good time to say that hey
they're here so we're gonna bring them
out you're such a jerk link this is okay
let me tell you our wives are not here
and I want to tell you something about
link okay you may know this already but
definitely I know this about link and
everyone who works with us knows it's
about link do I know it link his style
of joke is a joke that is only funny to
him it's like this no no no not all of
them I hope no no no I'm saying you have
this thing that happens just like that
was just like I'm gonna say something
right now and oh the only thing the way
the way these people can react is to be
disappointed okay I'm just I don't I
mean it's testing their fervor it's a
sickness do they it is a sickness like I
mean nobody's gotten up and walked out
so I actually that's what I need I need
to know that if I upset you you're not
you're still not going to abandon me
okay so it's it has nothing to do with
humor it has to do with a deep-rooted
insecurities oh this is a near biscuit
man like we got
okay alright buddy get serious I've just
a fear of abandonment by you guys okay
let's say you lie to them yeah that's
your application I'm not saying it's
healthy no but I I'm trying to I mean do
you have another example because you
gotta have more than one to say link is
like this you do this all the time okay
I do it outside with people it's usually
like in in groups of two or three well I
think it's the yeah just kind of adding
a little bit of awkwardness into any
small gathering you know turning turning
people against each other well okay like
which mean you know that's an
interesting thing because we I also do
like awkwardness a lot one of the things
that we have kind of discovered over the
years is that you know when we first got
started making YouTube videos and then
one of the early things that were doing
with local commercials right the red
house furniture and the TDM auto sales
and then what led to I love local
commercials and the commercial kings
we look that's it the favorite in terms
of what we've done that's the favorite
you know work that we've ever done we
love those commercials probably because
we're not in them much and we get to see
other people do things but they're so
bad and they're so purposely awkward
that we just like revel in that kind of
thing
but what we have found and you guys can
confirm or deny this especially with
like the teenage generation right now
they are so uncomfortable with
awkwardness that they can't watch it
so like we'll do we'll do something like
okay so we we did an episode of good
mythical morning where we one of the the
back-up plan
Geico sponsored ones where we were
Realtors and we did the open house yeah
so people were you know people were
coming to the house to try to figure out
if they wanted to buy it but we were
there to just screw with them right and
but also to learn how to be real estate
agent Groh yeah right and you know Oh
first of all
in general a great reaction to the
episode people really liked it but over
the years we've started seeing so many
more comments about like guys what would
you think those people thought when you
are trying to sell that house to them in
that way it made me so uncomfortable I
had to stop watching you guys feel that
way oh you're lying now you do in the
comments okay so you still like
awkwardness okay because I'd say that's
one of the reasons that we haven't made
any more local commercials honestly is
because people are like are you taking
advantage of these people and we're like
I just don't you want to have that
conversation anymore
let's the fine line obviously we don't
want to take advantage of people and
there's a there's a way to mess with
people that's like still just fun and
not at their expense but but there's a
it's not a hard line it's not black and
white so you gotta get you got a dance
around there's having fun man just
having fun mix it up you just have a
little fun I got another question here
which one did I want to read Hayley
Dowell where's that one it's right on to
the previous one oh you're not looking
at my screen oh no I'm looking at our
screens are not I'm looking at my screen
it how do you guys put up with each
other all the time
good question I'm glad it wasn't like
phrased towards one of us like Rhett how
do you put up with link all the time
well that was in there but I chose not
to read it I did I got this one how do
we what what's the real answer to this
there is a real answer but you know we
had a really good conversation with the
wasabi Bros on air biscuits was that
last week that was a week ago basically
embracing conflict well if this has
happened a couple of times it happened
when we had Smosh on as guests anytime
we have a duo we really like to start
talking to them about their process and
like how they get along because we you
know we've been working together for a
really long time and what you find when
you talk to somebody like Smosh or
somebody even though Mesabi Brothers
it's like they're younger they've been
working together for a long time but
they're kind of younger they haven't you
know we're getting old at this point and
we're like you guys haven't really had a
lot of conflict cuz we've like well how
do you guys like resolve conflict and
how do you argue with each other like
well we don't and on the if you go back
and listen to the episode last week with
the wasabi Bros like they had like this
lay into him at that point they started
talking about the fact that one of them
was they're moving out they've been
living together another moving out
they're still working together but
they're moving out and they started like
they hadn't talked about why and so they
start talking about why during the air
biscuit it was great cuz it was awkward
though but we like that but for us I
think the answer is what we told them
which is embracing conflict in order to
resolve it and just to have open
communication because I think the point
you know the first point about this is
is how do you how do you guys put up
with each other all the time because it
is all the time because there are a lot
of people who you know a lot of duo's
will like have you know they'll get
together to do certain projects or like
oh we get together on Tuesday we get to
we carpool I mean we are together from
9:00 to at least six every single day
and then probably talking to each other
about projects and that kind of thing
you know
over the weekend so it's I mean yeah
because it's like in nothing confessor
because it's it'll but any low level of
tension very quickly builds up when
you're spending that much time together
I mean if you're you know you know that
from any like committed relationship
type thing so you gotta get that stuff
out there yeah in there and there is
there is conflict I mean I think we've
been pretty open about that that's one
of the cool things about your biscuits
is that you it's more relaxed and you
know we there it's a lot of people say
it's like a therapy session when they
come on the show because we the way we
start asking questions but then we start
kind of talking about us and trying to
relate to the people and that kind of
thing and kind of processing different
things but yeah it's like I think though
I don't know I'm probably gonna get this
wrong but I think what we ended up
saying was conflict is guaranteed and
communication is key so in any in any
working relationship in any relationship
period there's gonna be conflict and so
we reckon we're constantly bouncing
ideas off of one another and working on
things and trying to fine-tune something
develop something that and we're in its
all the time and we're two different
personalities and we actually think very
differently and approach things very
differently which i think is a strength
but it's just you know it's also a
source of conflict yeah so and we
vacationed separately we do we're about
to do that actually we're not going to
the same place I didn't even know you
knew that I was going on vacation oh
yeah I'm going on vacation at the same
time oh man I thought I thought I was
onto something and we're actually
heading in opposite directions yeah
we're going two separate places were
literally like moving apart from each
other right and really we when we
shouldn't talk or we won't right no and
I'm blocking you and when we okay I'm
effectively that got some applause yeah
because we always joke whenever we
relaunch the new season of good mythical
morning it's like where have you been
but it's kind of true yes because we
will have been on vacation separate
right here's a question
morgen witted asks do you all have a
favorite episode of good mythical
morning we have a favorite episode of
good mythical morning there's a lot of
them they all start to run together and
then we'll be thinking about something
we want to talk about and I feel like
we've talked about that and then we'll
do it and then the comments will say
you've already talked about this that
actually has that's almost happened a
couple of times so they all start to run
together but you have a favorite well I
think there's an it there's an ironic
principle in this the episodes that that
are the crowd favorites are probably the
ones are the least favorite for us to do
you know select the willit episodes the
more we suffer the more people seem to
respond to those things but I think
there's a difference between the two of
us too and so let's not talk about what
our favorite episodes are but let's talk
about types of episodes because I do
anticipate a different answer
between the two of us of what type of
episodes are our favorites yeah Willits
are I mean they're they're very trying
obviously for me there
they're very trying but it's nice
knowing that they're going that you guys
love them and that they're gonna perform
really well you know it's it's really
nice to know you can put something out
there and that you're gonna not only are
we gonna be proud of it but that it's
going to work that it's gonna get a
whole bunch of views like that is a
great feeling having been having worked
on YouTube as long as we have and before
good mythical morning hey this is just
the psychology of why I love these
episodes even though I have vomit almost
a lot of dramas right evening usually is
because I you know we know there's gonna
be that return on investment before good
mythical morning really took off every
video was kind of like starting from
scratch in a lot of ways yeah you know
it was it was most likely a music video
and we knew it was gonna be
well-received but we didn't know if it
was gonna blow up so to speak and of
course we always you want that
so it's I love the Willetts because you
know they're gonna do well so that
really helps you know me stare down the
barrel of that trash can and actually be
happy about it but but those are my
favorite types what's your type episode
I mean I definitely like the information
heavy ones you know where we're like
breaking something open you know we do
it we do a lot of sexually not
physically right we do a lot of Lists
episodes because that's not just because
that's what works on the internet but
because it's a great way to think about
information that's why I Lister's
they've always been popular and will
always continue to be popular but I
think I like the ones where it's more
like oh this story about this guy who
hibernated for 25 years or this the
alien abduction ones where we each had
this the most convincing alien abduction
story because it because that's those
are the kinds of things that I would
naturally kind of read and think about
and talk about naturally because it's
there's this principle we talk about
this a lot like the way we want to
present information on good mythical
morning is the way that we would want to
present it at a party if we were like
hey you guys hear about that guy that
hibernator for 25 years
let's talk about that and then present
is not even the right verb in that just
have a conversation about it's like yeah
but yeah when we're at a party it's like
there's this you know you want to let's
talk about something interesting and
that's actually why we started ear
biscuits because we do this we we have
this tendency that if we are together at
a social function and we find somebody
who like has a weird job and and
sometimes they're like or a normal job
but I'm convinced there's got to be
something hidden we start asking like
this guy right here you know we would
say ask him some questions about his
weird camera and we were like get him in
a corner say wait you're the stick guy
like there's a camera on then the stick
it's like where is they where do you get
that stick and like what kind of camera
is that and oh oh this is everybody gets
one of these
yeah under your city this is like Oprah
this guy works for Google be nice to him
okay all right
it does say YouTube on his you know you
know paychecks but we kind of like we
team up on somebody who like yeah we
would be always like all over I guess
except septic tank pump guy he's like
man nobody's ever asked me so many
questions about my job y'all go
tag-teaming me up and that's not just an
example that's happy oh yeah yeah it's a
we end up talking to the septic tank guy
for 45 minutes and like he leaves with
his wife and I can only imagine man
there's these two guys I think they're
gonna start a septic tank company okay
because I've given them all the
information that they need but it's just
because we're interested in things so
but that's also why that was the kernel
that started good mythical morning
is it the kernel actually the kernel the
whole thing is this started been
sponsored by KFC like the stealth KFC
sponsorship no gonna be revealed in
Episode four thousand the kernel with a
K that started good mythical morning was
your tendency more than mine to have a
new thing that you wanted to talk to me
about
and so then good morning T Lincoln was
well we're we're carpooling and we're
talking about something we should just
put this on the internet which was then
weird because then we had to be quiet in
the car but then and then we would just
put it out there this is the 10-minute
conversation that we would have had it
you are and those are why there's still
your favorite episodes because you're
the different than medium I think you're
more the conceptual kind of thinker is
that what you say that's a good way to
put it I don't know you're kind of the
reactor yeah so like for me my favorite
episodes there's a little less there's
more pressure when there's something
that I need to think about and have to
talk about for you it's not pressurized
it's just I'm excited to talk about this
thing and I'm certainly excited to talk
about
you know alien abduction stories or any
of that stuff - it's not that I don't
enjoy talking about it but I think
there's a it's a little more pressurized
for me whereas where we when we play the
games and it's just okay just react just
kind of go on gut and see what happens
right or I like those because they're
they're a little less pressurized for me
it's like okay that by design what I
don't know is gonna happen if it happens
is gonna be the best part of the episode
for me or I feel like that's how I'm
gonna contribute at least that's how I
started to think about it and it so I'm
a little more it's easier for me to just
step into those episodes where it's
written like responding right and that's
why we do a lot you know we do both we
do a lot of different stuff so the game
formats are easy to step into I like
those the and then the like the physical
stuff we're doing stuff right and we're
gonna you know we're continuing we're
always trying to come up with a new
format within good mythical morning you
know that's like oh let's try baiting
each other about something ridiculous so
we're continuing to develop those ideas
and you'll see some of those in season
eight Ella house Abby asks are there
unpublished gmm episodes this is a
really good question
I'm published is probably not the right
word because I think that that would
imply that we had created an episode and
edited it and then decided not to upload
it that's never happened but what has
happened you might be interested to know
or maybe you kind of figured this is
that every once in a while there's an
episode that about five minutes then
we're like okay let's just start this
again and why is that like what would
what are the reasons I would say the
most common reason that happens is we
have like and this is a little insight
into whether you know how much this is
planned right so the process that
creates an episode of good mythical
morning has evolved quite a bit and is
much more structured
stringent than it used to be when it was
just like oh that I got something
this is trust me let's talk about this -
no let's sit down with our team let's
decide on what we're gonna talk about
then let's have our team you know find
the find the information kind of
consolidate the information so we're not
going off on the internet all the time
trying to find everything then sort of
reviewing it paring it down dividing it
up kind of figuring out I'm taking this
so it's not scripted but it's outlined
pretty you know tightly but it's so off
the show so off-the-cuff that sometimes
we'll start this riff at the beginning
of a list and realize that we just
talked about some we talked about that
septic tank guy for four minutes
and this is an episode about something
totally different and we're and we like
we're there's a timer we that's why most
of the episodes are about the same
length because whether it's a timer we
just don't have this innate sense to go
like 11 minutes and stop and it
sometimes would be like it'd be like
well yeah we kind of do but it would be
like a time or two
one of us would be like okay let's start
this again
I'd say that's one out of 20 right
because I mean let's can we'll continue
with that answer by asking another
question which was can you explain your
rapid subscriber growth within the past
year what has changed since then and how
have you managed this new level of
success I'd say one of the things that
led to just the rapid growth of good
mythical morning was kind of developing
the format so that when we say in
episodes about something with the title
with a thumbnail then we deliver on that
and you can you get that so we do you
know we'd like to there's this weird
dance because you we never want to be so
we never want the show to be rigid but
we want to we want to we decide to give
you guys something in an episode and
then we want to give you that but then
the dance is but we also want to create
in the moment so like if you start
talking about septic tank
and there's like this dance of
decision-making of figuring out I'm not
gonna go with septic guy or am I gonna
go back to UFO girl you know or or UFO
girl fo girl
yes she's awesome oh well she's uh she
yeah you've been researching her um yeah
I don't want to talk about it right now
because we'll say that we'll save it for
the episode what was my point my point
was exactly well what was my point I'm
not entirely sure I'm not Bob to barter
Laden he's a prophet no it was you got
to have that balance of am I gonna am I
gonna am I gonna give you guys what you
want in the episode and I think that's
the answer to that one of the answers to
this question is rapid subscriber goes
that we deliver on what we say we're
gonna give you and it's before we would
do an episode and we would kind of
discover what it was as you were doing
it right it was more like even if we
knew we were gonna talk about sometimes
we through it would like well it was
more about this conversation unless and
now it's like it's like I'm talking to
you
talking to you I'm talking to you and
talking to you the whole time but I
think a probably the most significant
thing that changed since the inception
of good mythical morning was you may
remember back in was it 2012 that we did
the mythical show that right I think so
so right at the beginning of 2012 we had
this idea to try the longer form thing
right the 30 minute version of good
mythical morning essentially called a
mythical show and we got some funding
from YouTube to do that it was part of
something called the creative creator
Innovation Program where they give you a
little bit of money to try something
that seems to be innovative on the
platform and that required us to hire a
team at the time we had first two years
were out here we had Jason remember
remember Jason who worked on good
mythical morning Jason Eman
is now hosting the DC Comics DC
all-access on DC Comics Channel that's
what he's doing now but January of that
year we hired Steve a shout out to
Stevie and that was kind of the
beginning of us building a team and
Stevie was very involved in in hiring
out our team to make the mythical show
and that was the beginning of us
functioning more like you know a team
that would create a television show it
was like okay this is a process we have
to be we're creating a quality piece of
entertainment there's a schedule there's
a certain standard that we're holding
ourselves accountable to and doing that
even though the mythical show wasn't a
huge success it was kind of wrong time
you know the wrong thing at the wrong
time we were proud of it and it we
learned how to function as a team and
then we brought that back to good
mythical morning that fall when we
restarted the show and so I think that's
the biggest thing is that we the process
has changed so much and then I think you
know serendipitous serendipitously is
that a word serendipitously
yes that's finish Lee providentially
there was a change to the way that
YouTube rewards your videos essentially
they changed the algorithm so that the
longer that people stayed on your
channel or the longer that your videos
led to them watching videos on YouTube
the more your videos got served up to
them and that's why it wasn't about a
view it was about watch time so yeah
whenever you know YouTube was smart
enough as a tool to understand that you
guys weren't just clicking on something
but that you were deciding to watch
basically the whole thing and you know
we always wanted to create something
that was you know I I'm not I'm not
creating a 10 minute video but I only
care about the first three minutes so we
also want we want to craft it in such a
way that you care about all of it you
know so
a simple thing very early on that's why
the wheel exists one so that you have
something to look forward to even if you
don't care about what we're talking
about something different what happen at
the end with this shiny wheel is
spinning and also we get to interact
with you guys and be fueled by your
ideas yeah so that that's one example of
a way that we we tried to craft an
episode and that the way that YouTube
worked it kind of came together yes I
think it was kinda you know the other
thing is just a whole bunch of videos
where yeah it was like that and then
they you would see one and you kind of
got sucked in through related videos
into watching other ones yeah so it was
kind of a combination of creating the
right product and then having the system
reward that product in the right way and
that's why there's just there was this
astronomical growth and it ended up
surpassing anything we've ever done on
our main youtube channel and now it's
kind of the hub of what we do and then
the kind of the reason that people
listen to ear biscuits and the people
that watch you know stuff on our main
channel which I think leads into another
question and I will add you know you
mentioned the team but I'll just mention
them again is surrounding ourselves with
great team members everybody on our team
shout out to all you guys who are here
everybody's not here so there's even
more of our team like still working on
stuff right now but you know that
they're great and they enable us and you
know we have learned to lean on people
and who are good at things to help us be
better at what we're best at so instead
of just doing everything and that's
certainly advice that we try to give to
I mean a lot of you are creators and you
aspire to expand and make more things
and you the challenge is finding people
that you can trust and you can lean on
and that they do things better than you
and then you can just take credit for it
like retina you publicly but yeah so
we're glad to give some props to the to
the mythical team
yeah and and unlike a lot of people have
commented in the past they're not all
interns it's just like can you guys show
the interns again well we have any given
time we have like one intern but they're
all like staff members employees with
titles and you know it's a production
company but they're paid in like
leftover Willet food yeah right that is
and they're okay with that for some
reason okay but you know seeing that
good mythical morning has become that
hub for so many things including what
we're doing on our main channel which
you may say is nothing nice you're not
doing anything on your main channel
mythical rank asked last year you talked
about doing more narrative content in
2015 are you still planning to do that
because it would be awesome we did we
talked about that last year I think we
did oh so yeah yeah we did talk about
that and we are doing it so yeah so it
sounded like a question no we are we are
doing it aggressively actually so just
one thing to note is that you know with
the growth of GMM and the growth of our
team and just transitions into a new
studio and things like that it's all
it's been very tough to manage and
continue to maintain the quality of the
show but we really really really have
every intention to create story based
content online so series feature films
that kind of thing so those things are
those things are being worked on so I
mean it's sort of the way that you'll
see that kind of rolling out towards the
end of this year is more sketch comedy
on the main channel kind of flexing that
muscle a little bit and exercising that
muscle which we haven't done very much
so stay tuned for that so the main
channel is not dead it will continue to
become more active do you want to see
more sketch comedy is that like a good
thing okay
and yeah not at the expense of good
mother good morning so you don't have to
worry about that so we're gonna that
that train will keep a role in question
from Tesla Lemery if you two were
stranded on an island would link eat
rhett first / Rhett eat link first
that's my type of question right there
observation we do we've talked about
this multiple times a week I like I just
love to keep talking about how they're
in a survival situation who would eat
well there's a lot of factors I think
we've both established our humor is
really dark well that's a problem I
don't know but is that a problem you
know I think this is something we need
to work out because there's a lot of
people out here who are gonna be in a
situation where their friends or family
members and and they're gonna have an
opportunity to eat them leave me like we
haven't talked about this is it a race
because the way that she framed the
question no no no no no it's not like
who's gonna do it first cuz this is
after one of us died so I think the
question is who's gonna die first no
that's not what she has she would link
eat Rhett first it would Rhett link
first there's no assumption of death at
all which makes it really weird I think
yeah one of us should die first
and then we should like process it well
I think that I am generally hungrier
than you
I mean we've that's been established I
like to eat more than you like to eat I
eat a lot more than you eat but I'm
smaller than you yeah right so therefore
so I maybe should die first and I should
eat you and I will live even longer than
you would live if I died first and you
tried to live off me that's perfect
that's true
and yes but it's not I mean you're
asking me to make the decision to die
first no I just mean I think the
question is who is going to die first
I've got a little bit of I bear a tire
that I can access for maybe a week
longer than you you were you gonna get
that where's the fat man
it's where's it gonna come from you
don't have any ID I want you to die
first
okay I think let's just is can we do
that are we talking about this we are to
aim there's people here even the spare
tire thing is supported that like you're
even supporting more like that's even
you want to watch you my spare tire
whatever it I can just picture picture
you oh gosh I'm gonna Maggie don't
picture me like chomping on like your
belly
it is much it's gonna chew as loud as
you two but there'll be nobody there to
hear it
you'll be sitting here oh and I'm
filming with your TMJ jaw just chewing
off my belly fat all by yourself well
I'll get yeah I'll get I mean chase will
hack you up Oh
burping chase you know how and he'll be
in the bunny cop really yeah we really
need chase we have to be you have to be
there okay how about this to wrap things
up did you just pick the final question
I mean you okay if you don't think this
is a good question to end on you know
the one the Jalen's asked what's the
weirdest unusual thing you received in
the mail I have to tell this story
because someone sent us milk are you
here it's the person who sent us milk
because we need to talk Oh in the back
there so no so Jen hey Jen Jen goes to
the post office she is the one who
retrieves the mail and she has a special
relationship with the person at the post
office because there's a lot of things
that come into our mailbox and of course
the people at the post office do not
understand why they're like I don't what
did they what kind of business do these
guys run and why are the boxes weird
shapes and decorated in weird ways and
have it's you know they're just they're
trying to figure it out but she went one
time and they were like kind of just
looked out and they were like come back
here and she follows never good news
when you're going into the back of the
post office she follows them to the back
the post-office and they're like we've
had this this has been sitting here
we've been trying to you know cuz she
doesn't go everyday this has been
sitting here for a couple of days and no
one will touch it and it was just this
box that was sitting there and someone
had just put full gallon jugs of milk
like multiple gallons of milk and you
put it in a box was there a reason was
there a stated reason they said will you
start a milk a club what like your being
in the Month Club thing that you do that
time but it was heinous it was that
these people had like gloves on didn't
they it like that's the name of the milk
club
and so that was weird and I gotta say we
we actually never saw it guys we never
we never drank it it was disposed of at
the look on location at the post office
still send milk please and I saw that
Stevie texted you during this thing she
said she's trying to produce this thing
even from over there via text she's like
just lay off but why did you but it was
I tell you what can I tell everybody
what you texted well I saw the text and
I was like what read it what is it says
she checks a puppy bite I know what she
means but for a second I was like wow
yeah I'm doing we're doing this thing
and all of a sudden in the middle of it
she's texting puppy bike but okay this
is what it is you have oh yes this is
okay so this is a good story have we
ever been injured video just you should
know this but now you have to tell me
exactly what you mean you have to say
tell them the story about the time you
were bitten by a puppy while we were
making a video so yeah you were injured
dude you should tell the story and Wow
to the point where this video never went
out so tell ya there's a lot of things
wrapped up in this okay so we did a
series of videos that were kind of
different like remember our Oregon Trail
video that was Oregon Trail in real
controlling like different physical
challenges afire by that but we also
wanted to do it the same day we did one
about gladiators like Roman gladiators
like we dressed up like gladiators and
we developed these physical challenge
games and we were that we were just
gonna make that an episode of GMM what
was in them well are we like had we're
like busting fruit so it's just a weird
series of challenges like our kids
dressed came out and dressed in togas
and threw eggs at us but one of the
things we had was you know gladiators
always battle animals so we got these
puppies these really expensive puppies
because you have to like rent them from
the right place and there's like a
representative from the ASPCA that has
to come when you use animals in a video
and so there's these really cute puppies
and the idea was because we had seen
another person do this online was to put
puppy food all over our faces and it was
you let this pack of puppies come in
lick the food off your face and it's the
person who laughs first loses so I
didn't see I kind of told them well you
should get like you know soft like mushy
food but I don't know it's um somebody
thought that got some chunky food and so
I'm sitting there on the on my back and
link is putting this really chunky food
all over me and it's getting into like
my crevices and nose and my ears and
they let these puppies go and these
puppies as you can imagine they were
they were hungry they were so hungry and
they one of them and those little puppy
teeth sharp puppy teeth they were like
this big
not the teeth the puppy it's like a
Megalodon here is a Tyrannosaurus Rex
got on my ear and could not
differentiate between the puppy food and
my ear and just grabbed it pierced the
top of my ear and just pulled and it was
like I and you see you said that you
heard like a pop I heard a pop and like
a rip of cartilage and my job while he
was your job trying not to laugh was to
just taught him so I was just I was like
laying into him like oh you could this
is so funny
you're gonna let I had no clue what was
going
just like yeah just look on your face it
was so intense I was like hi he's
playing it that way oh and one of them
was going for my nose it could have just
as easily been my nose but there was one
of my nose in one of my ear and right
when the ear thing happened i sat up
immediately I was like like Bobby Oh
like like flying off of your head
I'm bit I'm bit and then once they got
the puppy food off of my ear realized
that Joshy
it had gone all the way through and
ripped not all the way through my ear
but a lot a lot of ripich happened and
it kind of ruined their day it kind of
ruined the vibe for you a little bit I
was loving it I was like oh man and the
rest of the video didn't really turn out
so we never released that video we never
even edited it but in fairness I guess
you want cuz you definitely didn't
laughs and well and there's a I mean can
you there's that you can't really tell
it because people's ears are kind of
weird but if you look at my left ear am
i right here the left ear is totally
forever different because there is just
this weird bump right here from oh puppy
and it's all links well and then yeah so
but but you were so upset like I mean
you were in pain and you were mad that
it had happened and it was like there
was no salvaging the video there was
there was some kind of some conflict
that day yeah resolved it we
communicated about the conflict and I
thought it was great I was like yes this
is we got a thumbnail we got it we got
Rhett's ear ripped off by puppy that's
the title like I'm talking multi-million
views and it didn't hurt me at all what
loving it but you know in the end it
didn't look as if we were to put it
online it wouldn't look as graphic as
that actually was no and it was a really
ear pierced by puppy big deal could have
gone to Claire's you know okay guys
thanks for all your questions that you
guys submitted and you know it's so cool
to be able to hang out with you guys and
see your faces and hopefully many of you
will be able to meet us later for the
signing but either way we just wanted to
take a second in closing and say that
thank you guys for always being your
mythical best and for all your support
of us and for watching all the stuff
that we do and I see a lot of merch out
there and we feel all the support that
you guys give us in watching and hanging
out with us every single day
through good mythical morning so we
appreciate that thanks mythical beasts
yes thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]